est-ce qu'il y a un décalage au fond
entre les annonces de la France on vient
l'entendre Emmanuel Macron les annonces
de l'Allemagne aussi et la déception de
volodimeersky
c'est sûr que le président ski à temps
beaucoup de ce sommet de l'OTAN
peut-être d'ailleurs que il en attend un
peu trop la question que vous avez posée
tout à l'heure Julien j'ai entendu vous
disiez qu'est-ce qu'il y a de concret
parce que finalement dans ce sommet sur
ce premier jour il y a du concret le
président français qui annonce pas qu'il
va envoyer des missiles scalpes et qui
dit qu'il les a déjà envoyé montre bien
que il y a une action qui est mis en
place et c'est quand même fournir
effectivement un missile solaire à
l'Ukraine qui l'aidera dans les combats
qu'elle est en train de mener contre la
Russie d'autant plus que la France n'est
pas pourvue énormement de missiles
solaires donc en donnée à l'Ukraine
c'est effectivement en donner de la même
manière il y a du concret chez les
Allemands à partir du moment donné où il
donne 40 véhicules de combat ou qu'il
donne 25 chars léopard la déception
effectivement c'est que ce n'est pas du
matériel récent c'est du matériel qui
date des années
70-80 mais derrière c'est toute la
question on part quand même sur une
offensive en ce moment une offensive qui
détruit des armes qui détruit des
personnes surtout et qui fait aussi que
si c'est du matériel trop sophistiqué
qui peut partir et bien dans ces cas-là
il peut y avoir de la captation de
renseignements si les Russes viennent à
sans saisir donc il faut aussi que
chaque pays en fait trouve l'adéquation
avec tout ça plus une réalité à laquelle
on n'échappe pas c'est qu'il faut avoir
les moyens de fournir et que aujourd'hui
comme on était dans des pays qui
n'étaient plus en guerre et bien
évidemment on sait très bien qu'on a un
niveau d'armement qui reste quand même
assez limité et le Kremlin dit suivre de
très près le sommet Armel sommet qu'il
juge anti russe il y a toujours cette
menace d'une ligne rouge pour les aliens
pas franchir
oui c'est là où on voit effectivement à
quel point la crispation elle est
inquiétante en fait mais en même temps
c'est normal dans un sommet
international un sommet tel l'OTAN on
sait qu'on est sur un bras de fer et
qu'on est à l'apogée d'un bras de fer
d'un côté le président zénitins qui qui
dit qu'il a besoin d'avoir un calendrier
pour son adhésion à l'OTAN qui fait le
déplacement dans ce pays qui est la
Lituanie et qu'elle va s'adresser parce
que la Lituanie c'est un pays qui
comprend parfaitement l'Ukraine j'allais
dire c'est cette nouvelle Europe ces
pays qui sont complètement à l'Est qui
ont connu l'Empire russe à l'époque où
c'était encore l'Empire russe puis qui
ont connu l'URSS et qui peuvent dire
bien écoutez on vous avait prévenu
attention c'est un ogre voilà nous avons
une position qui est d'Europe de l'Ouest
où on est plus consignant effectivement
avec ça et donc le président zelinsky
qui arrive dans ce cadre là va parler à
un pays où il y a partout quand on se
promène dans les rues des grandes
affiches qui disent il faut que demain
l'Ukraine fasse partie de l'alliance
problème si l'on veut faire partie de
l'alliance il faut être en paix parce
que comme c'est une alliance de la
défensive justement vous jouez sur
l'article 5 alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer on peut imaginer à un moment
donné avoir une Ukraine qui soit coupée
en deux avec une partie qui soit en paix
ok avec life par exemple et où dans ces
cas-là qui pourrait adhérer à l'OTAN et
une autre partie qui appartiendrait à
qui qui appartiennent à quoi qui serait
effectivement une zone tampon sauf
seront des réflexions juridiques qu'on
peut avoir par exemple mais voyez bien à
quel point c'est pointu c'est compliqué
et ça ne correspond pas finalement à
l'histoire des pays ça ne correspond pas
à ce temps de la guerre dans lequel on
est alors effectivement on est là sur
des prises de position très fortes
j'allais dire que le Secrétaire général
soltenberg a aussi tenu un discours
aussi très anti russe sur la façon dont
il s'est exprimé en disant qu'il fallait
faire attention à cette guerre et
qu'elle pouvait à tout moment se dévoyer
on voit bien que les rues sont
parfaitement capté ce moment là dans
lequel ils disent effectivement encore
qu'il faut suivre ce qui est en train de
se passer suivre et acter et c'est
toujours dans ces moments d'apogée
j'allais dire que c'est là où c'est
presque plus dangereux sachant que les
Américains ont annoncé qu'ils allaient
envoyer des bombes à sous-munitions
alors que c'est un temps interdit par la
Convention d'OTA d'Ottawa que nous avons
effectivement signé nous les Français
sachant effectivement que l'on reconnaît
ici à l'OTAN que les combats sur place
sont effectivement difficiles
extrêmement difficiles dans un langage
globatique ça veut dire qu'il y a de
nombreuses victimes on est dans des
moments qui sont des moments très
sensibles d'une guerre qui peuvent
effectivement déraper à tout moment et
c'est pour ça que l'adhésion à l'OTAN
finalement évidemment c'est un grand mot
ici parce que c'est un grand rêve de
l'Ukraine parce qu'elle voit clairement
que la Lituanie par exemple aujourd'hui
elle est protégée par ce bouclier mais
aujourd'hui la réalité sur le terrain
elle est pour l'instant un peu autre
mais sur cette adhésion donc il n'y a
rien de concret merci beaucoup Armelle
charrier on vous retrouvera